he is the fox sports nfl rules analyst
and a long time friend because once uh
once upon a time he was the nfl uh
vp of officiating the head of nfl refs
and i was an nfl total access anchor and
we had a lot of great chats every single
week he is my friend from fox sports
mike pereira how are you mike
you know i'm good i sent out a tweet
this morning and i said i'm going on
rich eisen show and i said he wants me
on so he must have a rule proposal
he always has interesting questions but
there must be a rule proposal in the
back of his mind well here's what i it's
not really yeah well there is obviously
but uh it's not exactly a rules proposal
it's a it's a proposal to try and fix
everything at once how does that sound
what do you think i like that but then
if i if you fixed everything
all at once
i'd have a job
i like my job don't don't don't make me
unemployed okay but go ahead let's hear
it understood and appreciated okay so
let's start um let's start
with targeting because it in in it it's
in college football and we see it you
know uh in the nfl on occasion but
uh it's not nearly as stringent in in
the nfl as it is clearly in college why
is targeting so difficult
to be officiated consistently across the
board conference to conference game to
game mike pereira well i mean i think
that may be one of the best questions
you've ever asked because
because
it isn't consistent conference um by
conference and and and really it's hard
because there is a gray area and any
anything that has a gray area becomes
difficult because it it heads into that
area of judgment and you know targeting
started out more black and white than it
is now because
you know it was just a lower your head
and hit with the crown the crown being
defined as anything above the face mask
360 degrees around
the helmet
that was more black and white but it was
too punitive because you got you've got
players ejected when you know the action
really wasn't flagrant enough and
sometimes wasn't even intentional and so
there was an uproar because and there
should have been because you're taking
young men
and you're getting them thrown out of
games and if it's in the second half of
a game then he can't play in the first
half but the next game and and i for one
agreed that it was too punitive and so
really what they've done is kind of
backed off a bit
um in a couple of ways first they said
okay you have to confirm all elements of
it you know there has to be the
attacking motion and uh there is or a
launch to go along with helmet contact
and and that was
all good um and it helped to a degree
but now they've even gone a bit further
where they say okay
now the crown i know what the definition
is
it's above that face mask with a face
mask just above the face matter that's
300 i know what that is but now they
said okay let's make the crown the crown
the tip the top of the helmet not the
side um which used to be part of the
crown and so now they're almost really
working to
circumvent the rule to make it to make
there be less calls and when you do that
then it's become more of a gray area
type of call and until we get a national
body that's it which i think we're
headed to get we are you know yeah i i
do think we're headed to get that we may
see it as early as the cfp the the
playoffs this year where one body a body
of people who are
so-called experts will make all the
decisions when it comes to targeting in
all the playoff games it won't be an acc
replay crew here it won't be an sec here
um it won't be a pac-12 of course
because they won't have a team in it but
um
you know it's going to be
i believe they'll do it this year
there'll be a national body somewhere
located on the east coast that will make
all of the targeting decisions and
we may get to the point rich where
there'll be a central location that will
work during the regular season of
college football at least in the power
five conferences
to make those decisions and if you do
that
then to me it will be more concerning no
question about it all right so two
things first one uh was that a dog i
heard in the background mike is it that
yes it was okay
his first two doggies that he had up
here yeah were tuck and rule was that
what it was no no it was it was do you
really want to know what their names
were dez and he caught it that sort of
thing or
whatever okay what what what okay one of
the names of the dogs um it was
sarah and palin
you could you could see the you could
see russia from their dog house is what
you're saying
okay very good
all right and so the follow-up here is
that sorry sarah passed helen is still
with us okay well i'm knocking on wood
for for palin um so
who's in charge of this this cfp um are
they really going to just start
something new for the most important
games of the of the season is that well
they've experimented already okay they
did experiment they experimented in
um
maybe week one was it i believe it was
not week zero it was actually week one
of the uh
of the college season they experimented
with a couple of different games with
this replay center that they set up in
pittsburgh
and so they ran a test there to see how
it would work now you
you can't i don't think they they won't
be prepared i don't think and and this
is by the way it's not for sure but it's
a pretty strong possibility but they
they they won't be ready to handle like
all the bowl games
but they might in the future and um and
possibly when you do that then you think
okay okay we go cfp playoffs and then
next year maybe we'll go the
the the all the bowl games or the next
year maybe the championship games of
each of the conferences um i think it
will you know it will kind of trickle
down to effect where they'll be more
involved i i think it's needed i mean
and and i think it's a wise idea and the
right people are involved steve shaw who
is the um
basically the national coordinator of uh
of officiating for ncaa football
um you know dean blandino has had a hand
in it because he does also work with the
ncaa in replay
and he was on site in pittsburgh so i i
i think it's it's a step that needs
needs to be taken because
there
there just is too much inconsistency and
and and i i mean i thought i had it down
this year i don't in targeting i don't
have it down i think i knew targeting
you know when i saw targeting and this
year i don't know targeting when i
see targeting what i think is targeting
so
it's kind of gotten as i said back a
little more gray but the powers to be
recognize it and i do think we'll see
a marked improvement as early as the cfp
this year fox sports rules analyst mike
pereira former head of nfl refs here on
the rich eisen show mike and you just
said you know targeting you you don't
know what it is anymore sometimes
because you think you see it you don't
and you don't see it and somebody else
does and it's too arbitrary again that
they've lost the plot essentially uh
certainly at the collegiate level and i
think that that's what's happening right
now personally with ta with taunting and
the emphasis on the taunting rule in the
nfl mic is that we've applied the sense
of targeting to celebrations you're
targeting your celebration at someone
and that
it's an interpretive
uh flag i'm interpreting that you're
targeting someone your celebration like
say darren waller who spikes a ball in
the in the uh bench area on monday night
football even though that's the rule you
can't spike in a bench area wasn't it
anybody that was just him being all
fired up that he was actually targeted
by his quarterback for the first time
all night
and i think we've lost the plot what do
you say about this
i i think that we're we're targeting was
at the beginning where everything was
targeting and i think that's where we
are a bit although i think it's an over
exaggeration in that pretty much
everything is taunting um you know you
know i think we're making a little bit
too big of a deal out of it when you
think of in week one there were three
calls and week two a spike there was
eleven in week three there was two and
i'm not sure many how many there were in
week three but i know the one on waller
was one that you know to be was an
overreaction by the official um you know
he he turned away he turned away and
spiked the ball and so i i just think
that was
not one that the league would want
called look
um
yeah you know i am one to agree that
taunting has got out of hand and and and
when i say out of hand what when tommy
gets out of hand what is it i mean it's
the fact that games get out of control
and if you look at the last few years
most of the games got so chippy and when
you when they get chippy they're so hard
to control from an officiating
standpoint and i know that the league
has said that these coaches are the ones
that you know said we have to get rid of
it and that is true but then the
officiating department jumped on it too
because they have had problems in the
past few years controlling games and you
know i look at the league and say let's
go back to my day when i was in the
league and what was i was the president
of the no fun league
i was the one that took away celebration
i remember that might go to the ground
and guys like rich eisen were saying
what are you doing correct and um that's
right taking the fun out of the game and
i'm like okay i don't care but i think
it provokes ill will well the league is
backed off and now you can practically
do anything when it comes to celebration
um
and and so i think that's fine celebrate
do what you want you know do cartwheels
lay on the ground do anything you want
to do that's not you know sexually
subjective i guess is the is the only
one that you got to stay away from but
you know the league is saying hey we you
you're allowed to do this let's not just
do it at an opponent let's not get in
his face and taunt him after you've made
a great play because it does lead to the
bs that goes on after that and and um i
i i just think we're making too big of a
deal out of it right now because there
are so
few calls this is not like an emphasis
on offensive holding that created a
massive amount of holding penalties a
year ago
um
this is simply an emphasis not a new
rule
on showing up your opponent um celebrate
don't taunt and and if if we had
if we were having 40 in the game then i
would say yeah we got a problem but when
when you're looking at 3 11
14 16 maybe 18 calls at four weeks i
hardly think it's a
pandemic so to speak um and so i i just
and but then again the ones that i mean
several that i have seen called
i mean i'm saying
this isn't the intent of this the intent
was the prolonged into your face correct
quick turnaround look at a guy so let's
let's understand that this is not what
we really are looking for um and and i i
think it's already begun to show that
it's it's
already eased off from just a very few
to hardly any and i understand it's a
gateway celebration right a taunt is a
gateway celebration gateway to the
chippiness and nobody wants josh norman
and odell beckham anymore no
i get it
everyone understands it but these are 15
yarders mike these are game changers
these are these are drive stoppers these
are game changers and they're
unnecessary you know what i mean like
and it gives the impression to fans that
like you know where it's just why don't
you make sure that the hold is proper
and that the illegal contact is called
or not called properly instead you're
like you know plays over and you're and
you're throwing flags just for what like
to show that you're the you're in charge
you know what i mean it only serves to
piss off players and fans when it gets
when it gets missed mike well you don't
tell me you don't tell me that that fans
aren't pissed off when you miss pass
interference no i understand that of
course
or in the minnesota uh game
that they just had against cleveland i
mean fans get pissed off at everything
um you know and and i i get that they're
pissed off but those are football acts i
get that also and this this isn't but i
i do you know for this remember my past
history i was president of the no fun
ladies
i i do think there is a bit of decorum
that has to be in the game and i don't
think you should
necessarily reflect um poor
sportsmanship by getting in somebody's
face um when you have college and high
school kids that uh that watch these
games and emulate their idols and then
it always trickles down to the lower
elements of the to the lower levels of
the game and so um and again rich if we
were having a ton of these i would say
we may have an issue and more of a
talking point here but it's it's it's to
me it's there's not that many the
initial
um reaction in week two
when they didn't call a couple in week
one and they were told then the reaction
was okay well we got the word we gotta
call these and then they overreacted and
then they settled back down and i just
don't think that it's gonna be something
it's always the same we talk about
something and a point of emphasis for
the first four weeks and then basically
we're not talking about it in week 11.
and i think that's going to be the same
with the taunt i hope so last one for
you on this one and then we'll we'll
we'll end with the uh the universal fix
um
that
i remember when the celebrations in the
end zone and everywhere else were
outlawed and i remember it was the
owners meeting the membership meeting in
tampa florida and i remember going up to
you
in the lobby i remember exactly where i
saw you and i told you that this is a
big mistake and i remember the look you
gave me and you always would give me
this look and the look was interpreted
it's like rich i get so much from the
commissioner and the owners and the
coaches i don't need it from you
literally is like kind of like the look
that you gave me and you're laughing
because you i know that you know that
look
and you told me you told me that there
were letters
from coaches
at the high school and pop warner level
asking the nfl please do something
because the kids are doing it and you
said that that's part of the reason why
we're doing this do you think do you
know was that the same thing with the
taunting like where did this come from
the taunting emphasis mike where'd it
come well um i i honestly don't know
where it originated you know they're
saying that the coach's subcommittee
which uh you know they've listed the
names tomlin and and a lot of the other
coaches um you know harbaugh
that it came from them i don't know
exactly where it came from um but but i
do know that there's been kind of a
groundswell
with um
the feeling within the league that it
had gotten out of hand and and and i'm
sure that the officiating department has
a a part of this but then it goes to the
nine-member competition committee and
and i you know obviously it's a
different committee with the exception
of some back in my day i mean john mara
and rich mckay are still involved
and and and there wasn't a lot of
stomach even for it back then but then
it was more celebration than taunting
but um i i i can't say where it came
from they say that it came from the
coach's subcommittee okay i i believe
that but
um you know i i don't know how many
letters
that come from you know high school
coaches but i do know this that they do
work with the college conferences and um
and they they have joint meetings
together their rules committees meet
together and and i i know college has
always been sensitive the fact that the
nfl allows so much more in
unsportsmanlike convict my god god
forbid
if we got to the college game where if
you
the high stepped in in the end zone from
the five yard line if you high stepped
into the end zone out in front of
somebody you would be penalized for that
from the spot of the foul the five yard
line and they take away the score so
it's not nearly as dramatic as
as at the lower levels but i'm sure that
they had some input in that too when
they discussed this and they bet these
points of emphasis with with uh all
these different committees and and um
i i don't know again i'm hopeful at
least that when you call me in week 11
okay you're gonna be talking about um
you're gonna be talking about uh let's
see it'll be about the difference
between illegal contact okay and
and defensive holding and why the hell
in a third and 27 is it an automatic
first down okay ludicrous i will make a
note of that for our week 11 chat uh
last one for you mike uh mike pereira
nfl on fox rules analyst here on the
rich ass show former head of nfl refs uh
there was a play also on monday night
football where uh hunter renfro was
taken down by the front by his
breastplate in the front which is not a
horse collar because it wasn't from the
back uh it was from the front and it
looked like maybe the guy grabbed his
face mask and a face mask penalty was
called on review you're looking at it he
didn't even come close the face mask
okay
why can't 345 park buzz in and say you
got that wrong pick up the flag what
what what what is hawkeye you're hearing
about hawkeye fans hearing about hawkeye
what is what is happening and why can't
why can't the the central nfl say
we're seeing it's terribly wrong you're
so wrong on this sort of stuff
why can't we do this okay because the
nfl 345 is a mass unit maybe it's what
it is could be that pierce could be that
somebody from iowa i don't know i don't
get it but it's okay you know
listen they're taking steps now first of
all i thought that was a foul
you did that was from the front it was a
breastplate he didn't know it was the
side it was the side it wasn't the back
it was the side and you can't grab
inside the collar but they didn't
so i think it was a foul for another
reason but um you know listen what are
we doing we're talking about the sky
judge we're back to that conference
that's it you get the fix all guy which
which you and i we have been a proponent
of and i think it would work and i think
it's the most dramatic step that would
be taken in the history of officiating
that it could change things to a far
greater degree than any point of
emphasis or any rule change um if you
want to go that step we have said you've
agreed put an eighth official in a booth
give them the tv monitors
let them take a look and and and let
them correct some things so
the league said no
we don't want that but
we'll we'll let the replay guy we'll
call him the video assistant and we'll
let him make some decisions
and we'll make him let him make some
decisions in real time and so for
example we've had several plays already
this year where there's a sideline catch
and and the officials come together and
they're like talking and the video
assistant slash replay official sees
that it was clearly incomplete and
they've called it complete he just says
it's incomplete it's incomplete i got
the shot so they make the change boom
right then they make the change um
a guy that's and we don't know and we at
home have no idea that somebody got in
somebody's ear no idea we have no idea
it's because it's it's called video
assistance and so they're getting the
calls right right um without stopping
the game and having a challenge to be
made or something like that it's gonna
save time that's gonna correct some air
not that's not
called our favorite sky judge but he's
doing somewhat the same right and then
now it involves
lines ground and planes so it's not to
the area yet where it involves personal
fouls like hits on quarterbacks which to
me are up a little bit this year and i
think the needle has gotten caught a
little too far in protection but it's
not in those areas yet and then they
have what's called an expedited review
which is another use i think of replay
in a good way so the expedited review is
if they
see a play
and there is a play where the call on
the field is wrong
and that let's say it was a turnover so
it's the responsibility of replay and
they see it they just go they just
announce
um after review
the the ruling on the field is the
runners down at the one
what
after review
you never went to the sideline you never
looked at the monitor so an expedited
review so instead of taking that
horrendous two and a half to three
minutes which allows me time to go on
the air they cut me off
and so yes like so
so that's progress that's progress in my
mind um and and
you know and and under walt anderson and
perry fuel i i think it's working and so
they're finding that they can take steps
in real time to make some corrections
off uh you know on the field
so
will that expand
well let's look at history in 1999 we
brought replay in and it was just about
ground lines and planes but now it's in
judgment calls everybody have the ball
long enough was it recovered in the
continuing action um they'll they'll
grow with this and and maybe that growth
that video assistance
will become that god forbid that that
sky judge
who can be involved in all the decisions
so i i applaud the league or at least
taken this first step on the way to
satisfying rich eisen
and even the former vice president no
the former president of the no fun
league that's it
my career very good and speaking of just
growth mike you saying you know hey
something that's been advanced in the
nfl that causes you to have less uh uh
screen time that's that's also growth i
think from you
well done it's gross it's gonna be more
fishy and i won't be on the air
uh i assume you're heading to seattle
for thursday night the first triple cast
game of the year okay i look forward to
it definitely what a game that's gonna
be tomorrow night oh my gosh yeah it's
gonna be a great game i'm looking
forward to that and then i'll shoot over
to dallas and see the dallas and and the
giants play on sunday fantastic i look
forward to hearing you uh i'll always
love watching you and just uh chatting
with you thanks for the call mike
appreciate it you got it my friend take
care that's mike pereira fox sports nfl
rules analyst former vp of officiating
and former president of the no fun
league right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here